[موسيقى]
TVM يبدو وكأنه
بار يبدو وكأنه بار يتمتع بأجواء أنيقة لطيفة
بقدر ما نعرف ، نعم ، هذا هو أول
بار كوكتيل خالٍ من الكحول مخصص في الشرق الأوسط
كان عددًا قليلاً منا  كان يعمل في هذا
الشارع الفوري لفترة طويلة ولكن مع
الكحول ومؤسس العلامة التجارية ،
كان في عرض مثل حانة لمدة عام
وشاهد حديثًا عن منتجات خالية من الكحول ،
لذا كان لديه فكرة لماذا لا
يفتح  لا يوجد بار كحول
مع TVM Abu Dhabi ، الفكرة هي
تقديم تجربة مريحة راقية
للأشخاص الذين قد لا يرغبون بالضرورة
في التواجد في مكان ما أو التواجد حول الكحول ،
لذا فإن أول مشروب سأعرضه
عليك يسمى Tiki Street إنه  مفضل في
كل من أيرلندا وهنا مزيج من
الكركديه ودبس الرمان والليمون
والفانيليا أو الفانيليا القديمة من التوابل
الأخرى
مثل كوكتيل دراسة الحلوى ، كما أنها
منخفضة السكر وخالية من منتجات الألبان
وتسمى
زهرة الصحراء وهذا واحد مع الورد  الماء
والتمر  طحينة حليب الشوفان ومثل
القهوة الباردة المركزة
ومغطاة بالشوكولاتة الداكنة وبتلات الورد ، إنه
شيء آخر لذيذ نفعله هو أننا نقدم الكثير
من المشروبات الروحية الخالية من الكحول ، على سبيل المثال ،
قد يكون لدينا
مزيج نباتي مشابه للجن  لكن مقطرًا
بدون كحول
[موسيقى] ،
نقدمه فقط في شكل
كأس مربي الحيوانات قليلاً ، أضفنا القليل
من الدراما إلى التقديم فقط من أجل تحقيق
المزيد من الطقوس من شرب
الخالي من الكحول ،
ولدينا أيضًا العديد من أنواع النبيذ الخالية من الكحول
على سبيل المثال ، لدينا لون أحمر هنا
جيد حقًا للاقتران بالطعام
بدلاً من تناول مثل عصير الليمون أو
عصير
أجنبي
[موسيقى]
TVM في دبلن ، لم يكن لدينا
هدف واحد محدد كان متاحًا
للجميع وكنت مثل المحاولة وأخبر  هو مزيج حقيقي
من جميع الفئات العمرية ، وجميع الثقافات ، وجميع
الأجناس ، وهو الشيء الوحيد الذي
يشترك فيه الناس هو أنهم
لا يحبون شرب الكحول
[الموسيقى]